-Welcome, everyone.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. "The Tonight Show."
♪♪
Happy Halloween, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can tell I'm in
the Halloween spirit.
I've been wearing my
Jimmy Kimmel costume
for almost two months now.
Well, this is fun.
Earlier tonight, President Biden
and the First Lady
welcomed trick-or-treaters
to The White House
for the first fully in-person
Halloween celebration
since the pandemic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Yep, Halloween was back at
The White House,
and it was
a nice chance to reuse
Melania's Christmas decorations.
[ Laughter ]
Trick-or-treaters were psyched.
Every kid went home with
a bag of candy.
It was different than
the last administration,
when every kid went home with a
bag of classified documents.
[ As Trump ] Only take one.
Only take one
classified document.
Meet you at Mar-a-Lago."
[ Normal voice ]
I read that some of the
most popular Halloween candies
this year are
Reese's Peanut Butter Cups,
KitKats, and Snickers.
But there are
some candies out there
that people don't like as much.
Tariq, do you think
you can give us
some tips on
which candies to avoid?
-Do I? Hit it.
♪♪
♪ Candy corn,
you can take a back seat ♪
♪ You're tacky, waxy,
bad as rancid crab meat ♪
♪ Necco Wafer,
you're inedible rock ♪
♪ Just a swole-ass Smartie
that takes like chalk ♪
♪ Don't even get me started on
Good & Plentys ♪
♪ You taste like pennies,
more like Bad & Too Manys ♪
♪ And Milk Duds? ♪
♪ Get away from me ♪
♪ Won't get you out of my teeth
until Christmas Eve ♪
♪ And Jujubes,
you get an ew from me ♪
♪ I'd rather chew blue cheese
mixed with prune juice, please ♪
♪ And, Dots, how 'bout not? ♪
♪ You can rot in the box ♪
♪ Gimme Twix, Junior Mints,
anything but a dot ♪
♪ Gimme Reese's, Snickers,
Crunch, or Runts ♪
♪ But gimme Laffy Taffy,
and I'll punch your guts ♪
♪ I'll take anything
out of desperation ♪
♪ If the only other option
is a box of raisins ♪
-Oh, come on, now!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on. Come on, now.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Oh, my!
-That's amazing.
The greatest!
-Oh, my gosh!
-Tariq Trotter! Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hey, guys, I saw that,
this weekend,
former president Obama
was campaigning in Michigan.
And when he started talking
about getting older,
some women in the crowd
chimed in.
Take a look at this.
-I have to admit that sometimes
going out on the campaign trail
feels a little harder
than it used to.
Not just because
I'm older and grayer.
-Fine little...
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-I don't know
if y'all heard that.
Said I was still fine.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fine?
Then Michelle was like,
"Yeah, I think we're done with
the campaign speeches, alright?"
He's like, "I'm Barack Obama.
I approved this message."
That's the one difference
between Obama and Biden.
When Obama is onstage,
people are like, "He is fine."
And when Biden is onstage,
people are like, "He's fine."
"He's fine."
That's right -- the Democrats
have deployed Obama
on the campaign trail.
Tell me you're nervous
about the midterms
without telling me you're
nervous about the midterms.
Some business news.
In Elon Musk's first round of
layoffs at Twitter,
he reportedly plans to fire
25% of the company's workforce.
Meanwhile, Facebook said,
"We're hiring."
Everyone was like, "No, thanks."
But Twitter is actually
trying to hire replacements,
and we found some questions
on the application
that Elon Musk is sending out.
And here are
some of the questions.
They're very interesting here.
Let's check some of these out.
First one says...
-Wow!
-Next up, there's...
After that, it asked...
"V-Bucks, please." Yep.
Then it says...
These are odd questions.
-Yeah.
-And, finally, it asks...
-Wow!
-I don't know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good luck.
But did you see this, though?
Elon Musk tweeted something that
was considered misinformation
and then deleted it later
because it was
a false conspiracy theory.
Which is awkward when
you're the owner of Twitter.
Here was the e-mail
that Musk received. It said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a lot to figure...
Meanwhile, I saw that to reduce
the amount of misinformation
on their platform,
YouTube will now let
doctors and nurses
apply for their videos
to be marked as reliable.
-Ooh!
-Yeah.
YouTube finally looked at
all their misinformation
on their site and said...
-Ain't nobody got time for that.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So now people who
post fake information online
are freaking out, like...
-[ Bleating loudly ]
-Because if they keep
spreading lies,
YouTube might step in
and stop them, kind of like...
-The question is, how do
democracies respond to...
-And what will it mean for...
-But people need to know which
sources to trust
or they could fall
for anything, like...
-Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
-Or they might jump to wrong
conclusions, kind of like...
♪♪
-♪ Sail ♪
-So if you're spreading
misinformation,
it's got to come down,
kind of like...
And, please, always make sure
your sources are reliable
or nothing you say
will make sense, kind of like...
-What do you think?
-I like turtles.
-Yeah, there you go.
I hope that helped.
I hope that helped everybody.
"Hi, Billy."
-"Hey, Ron."
[ Both laugh ]
[ Imitates crashing ]
"Hey, Ron."
-"Hey, Billy."
Some more business news.
Spirit Airlines just revealed
upgraded, larger seats
that they're adding to
their new planes.
-Ooh!
-They're all on the wing,
but, still, it's something.
That's right -- larger seats.
But to maximize profits,
they'll make you
spoon with another passenger.
Well, get this.
I heard that nearly 150,000
pounds of chicken patties
sold at Costco
have been recalled
'cause there might be
plastic in it.
150,000 pounds of chicken.
Thankfully, at Costco,
that's just one package.
Finally, some thieves
in Georgia were arrested
after police found them
by following
a trail of candy wrappers
in the woods.
The judge must have had fun
with the story
because their bail was
100 grand.
I just want to say
to all the parents at home
eating your children's
Halloween candy,
you know what
you're doing is wrong.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, you can tell
today is November 1st
'cause all the Spirit Halloweens
have gone back
to being abandoned
Sears Outlets.
Let's get to some news.
Guys, the midterm elections
are just one week away.
That's right. In one week,
we'll know who gets the House,
the Senate, and the upper hand
at Thanksgiving.
[ Light laughter ]
You can tell
the midterms are close
when the fundraising e-mails
are in all caps.
"JIMMY, I NEED 10 DOLLARS NOW!"
[ Laughter ]
And get this --
as if the midterms
weren't already crazy enough,
apparently the country
is facing
a paper-ballot shortage.
Right now the MyPillow guy
is yelling at a tree
for rigging the election.
A paper-ballot shortage.
Now on Election Day,
you have to close the curtain
and just yell for
who you're voting for.
Like, "Republican, Republican,
Democrat, Republican!"
[ Light laughter ]
Well, President Biden
is working hard
to give Democrats a final
push before the election.
Starting today, he's appearing
at campaign rallies in Florida,
New Mexico, California,
Pennsylvania, and Maryland.
Yeah, if a jet-lagged
79-year-old
can't rally the Democrats,
nothing can.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Yeah, today,
Biden was in Florida,
which is a tough place
for Democrats.
I mean, right now
one Democrat in Florida
is losing to an alligator
with a mullet.
It's interesting.
Well, this is wild --
I read that Republicans
are expecting
former President Trump
to be indicted
soon after Election Day.
Yeah, it feels like
the political version
of waiting to break up
with someone
until after the holidays.
It's like, "Ah, just..."
Yeah, Trump could be indicted
for the holidays,
which sounds kind of like
a Christmas movie on MSNBC.
Speaking of
the former president,
Supreme Court Chief Justice
John Roberts
just temporarily blocked
Congress
from obtaining years of Trump's
federal income tax returns.
Yep, Trump was so excited,
he started chugging ketchup
like he'd won the Indy 500.
He's like...
Switching gears, now that Elon
Musk has taken over Twitter,
he apparently also wants
to bring back Vine
to compete with TikTok.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like it.
I think it'd be a great idea.
I also think it would be great
if they had a feature
where you could fast-forward
videos to get to the best part.
You know what I'm saying?
For example,
you could skip this part...
Yeah.
And go --
go right to this part.
-Ow!
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
I didn't know the first part
was that fast.
[ Laughter ]
-It snuck up on you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
it was actually -- you could --
you could actually
watch the whole video.
[ Laughter ]
That makes no sense.
Let me give you an example here.
You skip this part...
Yeah.
And go right to this part.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's what I want to see. I --
Let's give one more example.
You can skip this part...
Yeah, and go right to this part.
-[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-Flipper!
-Wow.
Guys, get this.
The makers of Ring doorbell
are about to release
their first car alarm.
I'm not sure how helpful it is.
All it does is let you watch
someone steal your car.
You go, "Oh..."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw that TV ratings
for this year's World Series
between the Astros and the
Phillies are the best in years.
So, naturally,
a lot of the brands
want to get their message out
to such a big audience.
But I was surprised
at some of this year's
World Series sponsors.
Watch this I saw.
-The MLB World Series
is brought to you by Twitter...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And finally, in China,
the winner
of a $30-million lottery jackpot
is not telling his family
about it
'cause he doesn't want them
to get lazy.
[ Laughter ]
It's just gonna be weird
on family vacations
when the kids are like, "Why is
dad in first class without us?"
It seems like there's so much
going on right now.
Everyone's gearing up for
the midterms.
The World Series is heating up.
The top-10 songs in the country
are all by Taylor Swift.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also, Stouffer's is releasing
its own Bloody Mary mix
that tastes like lasagna.
There's a lot to go over.
Let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
First up, the midterms.
They're less than a week away.
Republicans are trying to win
back control of
the House and the Senate,
while the Democrats
want to hold on to both.
Two sides going head-to-head,
kind of like...
the World Series.
Tonight was Game 4 between
the Phillies and the Astros.
Both teams are doing
everything they can
to prove that they're the best
in the country.
Speaking of the best
in the country...
Taylor Swift.
She's the first artist
to hold all top-10 spots
in the Billboard 100 at once.
That must feel good.
And if you want to feel good,
too, maybe don't try...
Stouffer's new lasagna-flavored
Bloody Mary mix.
It's vodka mixed with lasagna,
topped with a rim
of shredded mozzarella.
It's the perfect drink for
anyone who wants to black out
and forget all about...
the midterms.
It's a stressful time.
President Biden has been
touring the country
trying to rally support
for Democrats,
but the only tour most people
care about is...
Taylor's.
She announced her Eras Tour
this week.
Tickets aren't available yet,
but Swifties
are losing their minds,
foaming at the mouth,
which are also side effects
when you drink...
Stouffer's lasagna-flavored
Bloody Mary mix.
Look at this thing.
It's like a lasagna smoothie.
It's like a V8 from hell.
If you drink one of these,
you might get the...
runs.
You need runs
if you want to win.
Philly's going to go nuts
if they win, by the way.
Police are already racing
to grease up light poles.
Speaking of races and polls...
the midterms.
Dr. Oz is running for office
in Pennsylvania,
and you'll be
in a doctor's office
after drinking...
alcoholic lasagna.
In conclusion...
here we go...
time to vote...
what a show...
just no.
This has been a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Well, speaking of the midterms
and the World Series,
yesterday, during a speech,
President Biden
said that Phillies fans
are the most obnoxious fans
in the world.
Yeah. Meanwhile, Jill was like,
"Uh, Joe, is there something
you want to tell me or..."
And this was big.
Tonight, Biden delivered
a prime-time speech
from Capitol Hill
about the midterm elections
and said it could take
several days
for all of the votes to be
counted in some swing states.
And, unfortunately,
after these past two years,
every state is a swing state.
Yeah, a lot of experts
are predicting
a red wave on election day.
And you can tell Biden
is nervous,
because he already hired
Rudy Giuliani
to challenge the results.
Well, everyone's
talking about the midterms,
and a lot of races
are coming down to the wire.
Let me explain it all to you
with the "Midterms in Pictures."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
The midterm elections
are next Tuesday.
We're going to find out
if Congress is going
red, blue, or a...
different color altogether.
After months of campaigning,
voters are...
tired and cranky.
Watching commercial after
commercial has driven them
completely...
insane.
At this point, they'd be fine if
every candidate just...
disappeared.
But the election is
important for our democracy,
for our future, and for...
millions of kids.
Now, of course,
not everyone can win.
The losers will have to
take it on the...
chin and get sent away on an...
involuntary vacation.
Meanwhile, the winners will
feel great until
their poll numbers start to...
slide down.
The important thing
is that everyone votes
no matter what state
you live in,
because voting is the best thing
about America since it was...
born in 1776.
That was "Midterms in Pictures."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, listen to this.
According to prosecutors,
after storming the Capitol
on January 6th,
a group of rioters spent over
$400 at the Olive Garden.
That explains why
they changed their slogan to...
Switching gears.
Did you guys see this?
Adele just revealed
that her name
is actually pronounced "A-Dale."
Adele's name is
pronounced "A-Dale."
Or As her fans put it, "A-no."
They're sticking with Adele.
That's right.
Adele's name
is pronounced A-Dale.
I had no idea.
Did you guys know that?
-[ Scoffs ]
Of course I knew that.
I never mispronounce any
celebrity names.
Come on.
Give me any celebrity name.
-Okay, I guess I can test
you real quick.
I mean, who's this?
-Oh, that's easy.
Michael B'Jordan.
-Okay. Who's this?
-Disney Chanel. Come on.
Give me some harder ones, man.
Rapid-fire me. Come on.
-Okay, I'm not sure this is a
great idea, but here we go.
Who's this?
-Okay. Hug My Aunt.
Buns of Steel.
Gluten-free Mozzarella.
Macaroni and Cheese.
Oh, Moderna Pfizer.
Jake Gylla-Pudding Pops
and his sister,
Maggie Goo Goo Dolls.
-Wait. Why would their names be
pronounced differently?
-Well, it's like "Roozevelt"
and Roosevelt, you know?
Come on. Keep 'em coming.
-Alright, what about her?
-Okay. Hilarious Spanx.
Penis Quaalude.
Oh, Anus and Arms.
Colon Fart.
-Alright, I think that's enough.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate -- Thank you.
Thank you. No, that's good.
Steve Higgins, everybody.
That's more than -- Thank you.
-Adele.
-Well, here's some fun news.
This year's Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree
has been selected.
Yep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The tree is moving from
the suburbs to the big city.
Right now,
its parents are telling it
to always carry its wallet
in its front pocket.
That's right --
the tree is a Norway spruce
that's 50 feet wide
and 82 feet tall.
Although, it put 85 feet tall
on its Timber profile.
There you go.
And, finally, it's time for --
Yeah, Timber, yeah.
It's time for
our latest installment
of "Tonight Show Polls."
Here we go, everybody.
-♪ "Tonight Show" ♪
♪ Polls ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, this first poll asked...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
This next poll asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-Wow. This next one asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This next poll asked...
[ Rimshot ]
-Come on!
-This next poll asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?
-What? 80%?!
-Yeah, 80%.
-80%?
-80% said they do that.
-Wow.
That's how they eat it?
Sideways?
-Yeah. This next poll asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
This next poll asked...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
This last one asked...
Let's get to some news, guys.
I read that Jeff Bezos
may partner with Jay-Z
to buy the NFL's
Washington Commanders.
Bezos might be the only person
who has to stop and be like,
"Wait, do I already own
a football team?"
I'm rooting for Bezos and Jay-Z.
I never thought I'd say this,
but after the last few weeks,
I just want some
normal billionaires.
Don't you --
You know what I'm saying?
Can't they just be normal?
One of the big stories
today that I was reading
in the headlines that was funny,
Starbucks just rolled out their
holiday menu and their
25th anniversary holiday cups.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everywhere.
It's everywhere, yeah.
We're so starved for good news,
we're now celebrating
the anniversary of a cup.
We're like, "25 years of a cup!
Oh, my God!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tariq, you see this cup?
Let me text you this cup news.
That's right --
Starbucks just rolled out
their holiday menu and cups.
They even released
a special message.
Check this out.
-The holidays are here,
and Starbucks
is excited to bring back
all your holiday favorites,
like holiday cups,
peppermint mochas,
Michael Bublé CDs,
holiday cups,
peppermint mochas,
Michael Bublé CDs,
[ Distorted ] holiday cups,
peppermint mochas,
Michael Bublé CDs,
Oh, my God.
It's only November.
What are we doing?
No, don't question it.
Remember, must use Christmas
to sell coffee.
So, happy holidays
from Starbucks.
-Oh, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah! I love that.
Well, get this.
Today, Netflix launched
their new ad-supported plan
for only $7 a month.
[ Audience boos]
But this is interesting, though.
Apparently, some Netflix shows
have exclusive sponsors.
Did you hear about this?
I'll show you what I mean.
First up, "Grace and Frankie"
is exclusively sponsored
by Activia.
-Oh.
-You know,
it's exclusive to the show.
-Yeah.
-"Squid Game" is sponsored by
Black Friday at Best Buy.
I'm starting to understand it.
-Yeah, that makes sense.
-Yeah, next,
"The Watcher" is sponsored by
this photo of
Senator Mark Kelly.
You go, "Oh, wow.
Okay, buddy. Okay."
Next up, "Stranger Things"
is sponsored by...
October Kanye.
"Stranger Things."
-Wow!
-Next up, "Dahmer"
is sponsored by...
Impossible Meat.
-Oh!
-What?
-Wow!
-And, finally, "Bridgerton"
is sponsored by
Brookstone "Back Massagers."
For your back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Switching gears.
Last night at a train station
in Washington, D.C.,
President Biden delivered
a speech about
protecting democracy.
Yeah, normally, when a guy on a
train platform is yelling about
the country being doomed,
you just avoid eye contact
and keep moving.
Some more political news.
I heard that Florida governor
Ron DeSantis
is reconsidering
a presidential run in 2024
because he doesn't want to fight
former president Trump
for the nomination.
That's a bummer.
We were so close to a showdown
of Ronald versus Donald.
Speaking of elections,
the midterms are this Tuesday,
and there are several
key races around the country.
And while these races
can get heated,
it's important to remember
what the candidates
actually agree on.
Here, let me show you
what I mean.
First up,
John Fetterman and Dr. Oz
are facing off in Pennsylvania,
but they both can agree that...
Certain things you've got to be
able to agree on.
-Yeah.
-Next up, Blake Masters
is facing off against
Mark Kelly in Arizona.
They can both agree that...
Up next, in Nevada, Susie Lee is
facing off against April Becker.
They can both agree that...
"I'd just like to speak -- I'd
just like to speak to a manager.
Here's another one.
Angie Craig is facing off
against Tyler Kistner
in Minnesota,
but they can both agree that...
"Angie, there's no way
you're going to get this done
in three days."
Up next, Rudy Salas
is facing David Valadao.
They're facing off
in California.
They can both agree that...
-What?
-Next up, in Pennsylvania,
Matt Cartwright is
facing off against Jim Bognet.
They can both agree...
What?
-That's odd.
-And, finally, Raphael Warnock
and Herschel Walker
are facing off in Georgia.
They can both agree...
It's all bizarre.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, some entertainment news.
Yesterday, the new trailer for
"Avatar 2: The Way of Water"
was released.
And as you guys have
probably heard,
they shot the third movie,
as well, at the same time.
so, today, they released
a trailer for "Avatar 3."
Yeah, take a look at this thing.
-The way of water
connects all things.
The unforgettable characters
of Pandora return,
like Jake and Neytiri,
along with majestic new
underwater heroes, such as...
And introducing...
-That looks good.
Did you guys see this?
Elon Musk announced that
he's working with
Twitter engineers
on a reboot of Vine.
Yeah, that could be ready
by the end of the year.
When Viners heard
Vine might make a comeback,
they were like...
-Yeah, I sure hope it does.
-Meanwhile, kids who
only grew up with TikTok
are hearing about Vines
and thinking...
-What are those?!
-I mean, most people haven't
thought about Vine in a while,
so they were really surprised by
the news, kind of like...
[ Horn honks ]
Some people think Elon Musk
is making too many changes
over at Twitter
and getting carried away,
kind of like...
But most people are excited
for Vine to return,
so here's hoping Elon
doesn't mess everything up,
kind of like...
-[ Sneezes ]
-"Nice, Ron."
Well, listen to this.
Next month, a model for E.T.
used in the movie
is expected to sell at auction
for $3 million.
That's kind of cool,
but I don't know
who's going to buy that though,
you know?
I'm going to buy him!
Excuse me, sir?
I said, I'm gonna buy me an E.T.
I've been waiting
my whole life for this moment.
I can use that dang E.T.
for all sorts of things.
[ Laughs ]
Like what?
Well, I figure I can rest my
coffee mug on his head.
I can put a wig on him,
take a picture,
and make it my profile picture
on my MySpace.
[ Laughs ]
I don't think people use
MySpace anymore.
Yeah, I got all sorts of plans
for uses for an E.T.
I can put him next to the dishes
and make it look like
he's warshing the dishes.
[ Laughs ]
Oh! I can take him to
a baseball game,
tell the stadium
it's his birthday,
then get him on the jumbotron
and have it say,
"Happy birthday, E.T." on it."
And then, while everyone
is distracted wishing E.T.
a happy birthday,
I can steal a bunch of hot dogs
from the concession stand.
Then I got my dinner for
a whole year.
[ Laughs ]
Sounds like a plan,
but where are you going to get
$3 million to pay for it?
Well, don't worry about it.
Just check me out on OnlyFans.
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, I saw that today is
National Sandwich Day.
-Yeah!
-That's today.
National Sandwich Day.
Hot-dog vendors were like,
"Do we celebrate this or..."
It's going to be a fun weekend
here in New York City
because this Sunday
is the New York City marathon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's this weekend.
Is anyone here
running the marathon?
-Yeah!
-Yeah?
[ Applause ]
I'm sure
that won't be the last time
we hear you're running
the marathon.
[ Laughter ]
Good luck for you, by the way.
A little trivia for you.
I heard that the fastest
marathon runners
can hit a top speed
of almost 13 miles an hour.
[ Audience murmurs ]
Then everyone
who drives a Kia Sportage
was like, "Big deal, so can we."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
people from all over the world
are competing in this marathon,
and it's very interesting --
the city is adding some new
obstacles along the route
to give runners the full
New York experience.
I'll show you what I mean.
In Times Square...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
Down in Staten Island...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Over in Washington Square
Park...
[ Laughter and applause ]
At this point...
[ Laughter ]
As they go up
near Central Park...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Right over here...
[ Applause ]
Very cheap.
Also at this point...
And finally,
once they finish the race...
There you go.
The runners will.
Good luck to everyone
running the marathon.
Meanwhile,
early on Sunday morning,
Daylight Savings Time ends.
So, you'll gain an hour.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
At 2:00 a.m.,
all the clocks turn back an hour
while every bartender
lets out an audible sigh.
Whew! [ Sighs ]
Well, let's get to some news.
With midterms
just a few days away,
former President Trump is going
on a final campaign blitz.
At a rally last night in Iowa,
Trump hinted that he's
going to run again in 2024,
but he did it in
a pretty odd way.
Watch this.
-I will very, very, very
probably do it again, okay?
Very, very, very probably.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Trump ] It's like my
favorite book,
"The Very, Very, Very Probably
Hungry Caterpillar."
[ Laughter ]
Very, very, very, very,
probably.
[ Applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
It's also how Trump
recited his wedding vows.
[ As Trump ] I very, very,
very probably do.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Some more news on the midterms.
Oprah, who launched
Dr. Oz's career,
just endorsed his opponent,
John Fetterman.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Apparently, this year, one of
Oprah's favorite things is...
betrayal.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Oprah endorsed Fetterman,
which explains why Dr. Oz
just tweeted this.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Oz and Fetterman,
during last night's
World Series game,
I don't know if you saw this,
I noticed that ads
for the two candidates
aired back-to-back.
And the timing was pretty great.
Check this out.
-Together, we'll stand up
to extremism on both sides
and bring balance to Washington.
I'm Dr. Oz.
I approve this message.
-Oz is a piece of [bleep]
in my opinion.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dr. Oz was like,
"The proper medical term is
piece of stool sample."
[ Laughter ]
Well, a lot of people
are talking about this.
Jeff Bezos
is thinking about buying
the Washington Commanders.
Did you see that? Yeah.
Well, yeah, this guy
might become an NFL owner.
So we decided
to ask some NFL players
if they want to play for Bezos,
and here's what they said.
First, Trevor Lawrence
from the Jaguars said...
And Brendan Schooler
from the Patriots said...
Next, Andrew Van Ginkel
from the Dolphins said...
Then Billy Price
from the Cardinals said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next, Lane Johnson
from the Eagles said...
Then Brian Hoyer
from the Patriots said...
And finally, Las Vegas Raiders
owner Mark Davis said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, get this.
The M.T.A. just released
a new subway bingo game
to make riding the train
a fun experience.
[ Laughter ]
The M.T.A. said, "Well,
it's the least we could do."
And New Yorkers were like,
"Clearly."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the bingo card has things
like escalator, wooden bench,
and business man getting kicked
in the face by a break dancer.
It's fun.
Well, hey, I saw this
for the holidays,
Miller Lite is releasing
a pretty wild contraption.
Take a look at this.
-Beer brand Miller Lite
is releasing
a Christmas tree keg stand
this holiday season.
Its fully functioning tree stand
is designed to fit around
a quarter-barrel keg.
Its design makes it seem
like beer is being poured
from the tree.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ I'm dreaming
of a white trash Christmas ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you thought the Christmas
tree was lit before...
Yeah.
Kids will be like,
"I saw Mommy
dragging Santa Claus
to the couch."